START WITH MADAME SAID MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
BERMAN HERE GALLAGHER HERE
MAYES FEAR CALDERON HERE WEBER
HERE LOW. MULLIN ALL RIGHT
MISTER LESSER FORM WHILE WE GET
STARTED IT WITH SOMEONE NEVER
SURVIVE THIS IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL WHICH
NUMBER I DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF
ME PERFECT TIMING. AB ONE
EIGHTY TWO OH ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'D SAY EVERYTHING EACH
SO WHEN THE TEXT MESSAGE
DISCLOSURE. I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR THE WORK RAFI
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL ARE. ON THAT LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD BY REFERRING
DISCLOSURE. EVEN FOR ONE MY
CLASS THIS YEAR. REGULATION FOR
COMPLEX MESSAGES WHILE FIRES
CAN YOU WHERE YOU WANT TO
TWENTY. I WOULD BE CLEAR
WITHOUT THIS BILL I NEXT YEAR
WILL BE THE WILD WILD WEST I
SPORTS CAN'T. WE UNLIKELY THE
BILL. THERE MUST BE A BALANCE
PROVIDED WITH VOTERS WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEEDED
ONE OUT. ALSO BEING OVER FOR IT.
I JUST WANT TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. IS THIS FOR YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I GUESS
GETTING INUNDATED WITH TODAY
I'M HAVING MY OWN FIRM WELL
VERSED CONSULTING REPRESENT A
COMPANY CALLED THREE. A ADD
TEXT MESSAGING COMPANY THAT
OPERATES A SECURITY FOR TEXT
MESSAGING PLATFORM SENT OUT
ALWAYS RELATED TEXT MESSAGES I
WOULD ASK FOR AN OUT OF A
OBVIOUSLY THEY'LL I WOULD SAY
THERE IS A RUMOR CIRCULATING
AROUND THE CAPITAL ON. THIS
BILL THAT SUPPOSEDLY WAS STILL
STANDS. I JUST WANTED YEAH THIS
IS NOT THE CASE. THAT'S. LIKE
US FOR GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PLEASE HELLO I WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU I PRINT
LÏNG HEALTH OF THE MOTHER
CAMPAIGN VERY PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL THIS IS A VERY GOOD
DISCLOSE THAT BUILDING CLOSE A
CLEAR RECALL WORK VERY
CAREFULLY TO MAKE IT IS
REASONABLE AND SHORT AS
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT. ALL
TYPES OF MEDIA HAVE TO DISCLOSE
THEIR TOP ON DOWN BY THE TEXAS
THIS IS A QUESTION AND FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL IN THIS ISN'T
SUPPORT YEAH AND IN MANY PLACES
FOR PROGRESS WE'RE THE ONE FOR
CENTERS IN SOCIETY WHO FIGHT
ALONGSIDE THEIR ADS 99% IN
WORKSHOPS FOR THIS DOLLARS
WHILE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING RESEARCHER
REMEMBER STANDARD FOR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION I AM I
FIRST LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES FOR
TAKING MOST OF THE MEMBERS ARE
REQUESTED BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S STILL SOME WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE ON THIS BILL
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE BILL BE
HELD. WHILE THE WORK ON OTHER
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS AND.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU AGAIN FOR.
TAKING OUR OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
SELF AND THE FIRST REGULAR
CLASSES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HI GERMAN MEMBERS
TERRY BRENNAN PASSED THIS YEAR
YOU CALIFORNIA. FIRST I'D ALSO
LIKE THINK THE AUTHOR. AND THE
STAFF INCLUDING MANY STAFF FOR
HELPING US WORK THROUGH THIS.
AND RESOLVE A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT CREATES ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES. THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE AND IMPORTANT GOT
CONSEQUENCES. ARE REMAINING.
ISSUE WAS THE CREATION OF THIS.
NEW CATEGORIAS ON STATE.
VOLUNTEER WHICH DOESN'T EXIST
ANYWHERE ELSE RIGHT WE'VE
OFFERED A MINISTRY TO FIND
WHICH WERE IN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
ONE MYSTERY LOS BILL I THINK
APPROPRIATE DESCRIBED THE
REASON ISN'T VOLUNTEER IN THE
SITUATION. THAT WAS NOT
ACCEPTED PART. OF THAT PROCESS
THE TINY THE LATEST SEVEN. THE
LATEST OF CONVERSATIONS BUT
SUFFICE IT TO SAY WITHOUT THAT.
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR US TO BE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN POSTED THE
BILL THAT BILL PASSED OUT FIFTY
EIGHT WITH FIFTY ABOUT SKIMMING
FAMILY FLOOR BY THE WAY. WHERE
DO YOU SHOULD BE OUR GOAL HERE
I CONFUSION THAT WAS OUR
EFFORT. WE UNDERSTAND YOU.
DON'T HAVE MANY OPTIONS HERE
PASS AND HELP. OR THE WHOLE
COMMITTEE MY PREFERENCE WOULD
BE FREE TO HOLD IN COMMITTEE
AND RESOLVE IT ALONG WITH THE.
CO AUTHOR SCALE TWELVE
SEVENTEEN MR MELONES OFFERING
SHORT OF THAT. TO WORK ON THIS
THE OTHER P. R. E. BILLS TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE. WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL. HOW CAN US
WHERE WE WANT TO BE I DON'T
THINK IT'S AN IMPEDIMENT GOALS
AND BILL WHICH ARE INCREASING
DISCLOSURE. WHAT HAPPENED TO
HER AND SOME OTHER I'M SORRY
WHAT HAPPENED THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN SOME OF THE
CANDIDATES IS UNFORGIVABLE. AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE BACKSTOPS AS
WELL. THANK YOU FOR TALKING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
COMPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS MISSILE WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. ALSO IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY AS HE I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK YOU SOMETHING
NUMBER FOR ALL ON THE BILL AND
AGREED THAT. THERE IS AN ISSUE
FOR NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
THERE ARE SOME SPECIFICS WITH
THE WAY THAT THIS BILL IS
CRAFTED WITHOUT SOME. SORT OF
LIKE HOW TO WORK AND BACK AT
THAT TIME. ALSO REFLECT THAT CA
FOR PRESIDENT HELLO AND THANKS
FOR CALLING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND THE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THIS
PROCESS IS GOING TO NAME AND
ORGANIZATIONS ARE. THERE ARE
NOT WITH THAT OPEN UP THE CALL
USE QUESTIONS COMMENTS WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND ALREADY
MISTER MULLIN. JUST WANTED TO
THANK MY TELEPHONE ON THEIR-
MINDS AS FOR. THIS ISSUE. AS
YOU KNOW. VITAL DISCLOSE ACT
THAT BECAME LAW ON THIS WAS AN
OMISSION FROM THAT LOFTY SO I
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY ONCE
EVERY UP ON THIS ISSUE PROJECT
HARDER WITH HER ALL. HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF EXTENSIVE
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS AND SERVE. THIS
FLOOR AND HAVE ABOUT. THIS
MONTH ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. IT'S
AROUND THIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WELL I APPRECIATE THE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD I DO WANT TO KNOW I TAKE
INTENDED OUT OF THE LOGIN
AMENDMENTS FROM BEHIND THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE JUST SPOKEN SO
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON SOMETHING NEXT YEAR
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS BILL IT'S NOT GERMANE TO
THE ISSUE THE PAY RAISES ON FOR
ME TO THIS FILM PARTICULAR AND
HAPPY TO. NATIVE ALONG WITH
OTHER MEMBERS WHO SHARED FOR WE
CAN DO NEXT YEAR TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS IN A
SEPARATE ISSUE GREAT
RESPECTFULLY ACTUALLY I ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH FOLKS
OPPOSITION ON THE CONCERNS OF
THE AD HAVE AND THE COMMITTING
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
FOLKS TO ADDRESS ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT EXIST I
SUPPORTED THIS BILL WHEN WE
HEARD IN APRIL I CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE IS CLEAR DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS FOR POLITICAL TEXT
MESSAGES SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL. AND I
RECOMMEND AND I BOUGHT WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL VOTE THE
MOTION IS WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THE SECOND AMENDMENT
SPEAKER. BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE
GALLAGHER. THE BABY'S.
GALLAGHER. I KNOW RIGHT NOW I
NEED. MULLIN MULLIN AYE.
WHATEVER DEVILS OUT ON A SEVEN
OH VOTE CONGRADULATIONS. AND
NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY ONE. THE
MULTIPLE TRACK. THERE WAS
PERCENT AND THEN THE THIRD. AND
THE FOURTH THING WITH OKAY.
OKAY READY WHEN YOU ARE SOMEONE
NUMBER GONZALEZ SIXTY ONE IS
BACK WORKING CURRENT. YES I GET
A MOTION A SECOND. I KNOW THE.%
THANK YOU ANYONE IS IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WELL CREDIT IN THE ROOM ENOUGH.
CALIFORNIA WILL WIN BUT-
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE MOVING
INTO COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE THE
SUMMARY IS ALREADY LIKE A CLOSE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
SUPPORT THIS BILL WHEN WE HEARD
IN APRIL IT HAS BEEN
SUBSTANTIVELY AMENDED SINCE A
LOT OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS WHICH
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS FOR
VOTERS TO CHANGE THEIR ADDRESS
OR POLITICAL PARTY PREFERENCE
WILL BE MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
VOTERS IN ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
ON I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. TO CREATE A
NOTIFICATION PROCESS THAT WILL
REDUCE CONFUSION AND INFORM
VOTERS OF THEIR BALLOT OPTIONS
I STILL REMEMBER BEING ASKED
ABOUT THIS WHEN I WAS GOING
DOOR TO DOOR IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN A MILE ACTION I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND
RECOMMEND SOME MORE SUPPORT
THAN SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL
ABOUT THE MOTION IS WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT. BERMAN
GALLAGHER COLOR HI HOW ARE YOU.
LOW I'M MAYES FIVE DAYS I
MULLIN. THAT BILLS ON A SEVERAL
RESOLUTIONS ON A RECORD IT.
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT MISTER BERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER EVANS. THE GERMAN IN
COLLEGE AB SEVEN THIRTY SIX TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS THAT HE HAD THE
TWENTY TWENTY. AS MORE MORE BAD
ACTORS TRY TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTIONS WITH MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS THAT SO CONFUSION AND
DOUBT WITH VOTERS. I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT VOTERS HAVE
A RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN VIDEO
AUDIO AND IMAGES THAT THEY'RE
BEING SHOWN HAVE BEEN
MANIPULATED AND DO NOT
REPRESENT REALITY WITH ABOUT
SECOND THIS IS BECOME MORE
CHALLENGING WITH THE INVENTION
OF THE FACE. WHICH ARE
EXTREMELY CONVINCING TRAVEL DID
PHOTOS VIDEOS AND AUDIO
RECORDINGS OF SOMEONE. TO SAY
OR DO SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
ACTUALLY SAY OR DO I APOLOGIZE
I GONNA. SINCE THIS IS A GUY I
MET IN THIS UP OR SOMETHING
THAT GOING TO IS A LITTLE BIT
FOR OBVIOUS AS POSSIBLE. AB
SEVEN THIRTY WOULD PROHIBIT A
PERSON FAMILIAR ENTITY WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OF AN ELECTION FROM
DISTRIBUTING WITH ACTUAL MALICE
MATERIALLY DECEPTIVE AUDIO OR
VISUAL MEDIA WITH INTENT TO
INJURE. THE CANDIDATES
REPUTATION ORDER DECEIVER VOTER
IN THE VOTING FOR AGAINST. IT
AND ONCE THE MEDIA INCLUDES A
DISCLOSURE STATING THAT IT IS
BEING MANIPULATED. THE ABILITY
TO A SPEECH IN CONTACT WITH
CAñADA THAT IS FALSE THAT
NEVER HAPPENED MAKES DEPICTS A
POWERFUL AND DANGEROUS NEW TOOL
IN THE ARSENAL OF THOSE THAT
ONE WAY TO MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN. IN JANUARY THEN US
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE DAN COATS ONE THAT
HE TAKES WILL PROBABLY BE AMONG
THE TACTICS USED TO DISRUPT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION. EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE US HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM IT SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLIGENCE BUT I
CONGRESS MEMBER ADAM SCHIFF
CONVENE A HEARING ON THE
NATIONAL SECURITY CHALLENGE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
MANIPULATE IMMEDIATE AND THE
FACE. AND NOTED THAT THE FACE
RAISE PROFOUND QUESTIONS ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY AND
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNANCE WITH
INDIVIDUALS AND VOTERS NO
LONGER ABLE TO TRUST THEIR OWN
EYES OR YEARS. WHEN ASSESSING
THE AUTHENTICITY OF WHAT THEY
SEE ON THE SCREEN. THIS IS NOT
A PARTISAN ISSUE ANY US SEVEN
POLITICS HEARING SENATOR MARCO
RUBIO SAID THAT HE EXPECTED THE
CASE WILL BE USED. THE NEXT
WAVE OF ATTACKS AGAINST
AMERICAN WESTERN DEMOCRACIES.
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY OPTIONS
ON A CORNER WE MUST DO MORE FOR
THE PROLIFERATION OF THE FACE
AN AUTOMOBILE RELATED MEDIA. I
UNDERSTAND THEIR- CONCERNS BUT
I WOULD NOTE THAT NO FOR THAT
I'M AWARE OF HIS FOUNDED THE
FIRST AND THEN THE- BRANCH
SOMEONE THE RIGHT TO LITERALLY.
THEIR WORDS I MIGHT. HE SAID.
YOUR MEMBERS NEVER KALRA HAVE
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND ACLU IN
OPPOSITION APPRECIATE. THE WORK
AUTHOR HAS DONE IN TERMS OF
AMENDMENTS BUT YOU STILL HAVE.
THERE IS CONCERN ABOUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IMPLICATIONS IN
PARTICULAR THE TYPE OF CONTENT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS CALL
THE D. FATE FOR A REASON
THEY'RE VERY DIFFICULT TO
ASCERTAIN IF THEY'RE REAL OR
FAKE. AND SO IN IN FACT ASKING.
A BROADCASTER OR ASKING THE
CABLE NETWORKS TO POLICE THAT
CONTENT. AND BE LIABLE IF THEY
DO NOT JUST. YOU'RE CREATING
REALLY A CHILLING SITUATION
PARTICULARLY ON POLITICAL
FREEDOM OF SPEECH BECAUSE THE
DEFAULT IS TO BE TO NOT. JUST
CLOSE ARE NOT AT A SEASON TO
NOT ACTUALLY SURE THIS
INFORMATION WHY WOULD YOU DO
THAT FOR SUBJECT TO LIKE LEAVE
YOURSELF CAN BE VERIFIED
CONTACT FEDERAL SO WE DO HAVE
SUCH CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
THERE'S AN ISSUES. THIS IS.
CERTAINLY NEW TECHNOLOGY. THE
WORKER DOING TEACHING IN
OPPOSITION. ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. THE ONE THAT I HAD
ON THE I MEAN I KNOW ONE OF THE
ISSUES HERE IS TRYING TO BE. AS
NARROWLY TAILORED AS POSSIBLE
TO GET I THINK THE ISSUE THE.
THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED WITH
THESE DEEP FAKE VIDEOS THAT CAN
BE USED TO SHOW SOMEONE SANE OR
EXPRESSING SO THAT THEY CLEARLY
DIDN'T SAY. ONE CONCERN HAS
BEEN BROUGHT UP IN OUR ANALYSIS
IS JUST THAT. THE WAY THE
WORDING IS RIGHT NOW IF YOU
COULD MAYBE ALSO APPLY TO LIKE
LET'S SAY. AND I THINK THIS
HAPPENS A LOT SOMEONE TAKES
JUST A CLIP OF WHAT YOU SAID.
YOU KNOW. AND SO IT'S IT IS
MANIPULATING ITS MANIPULATE THE
VIDEO. BY NOT GIVING YOU THE
FULL CONTEXT BUT OF COURSE THIS
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME POLITICS
RIGHT A I TOOK THE CLIP OF ONE
PORTION OF YOUR SPEECH PUT THAT
UP THERE. I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD SAY HEY THAT'S
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
SPEECH IT IS WHAT YOU SAID EVEN
IF IT'S NOT. IN CONTEXT AND IN
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS. AND IN THE
HEAT OF A FOR YOU KNOW A LOT OF
TIMES THAT POLITICAL SPEECH IS
TREATED AS EXTRA PROTECTION.
FOR THE- YEAH HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN I DON'T
THINK THAT. SITUATION APPLIES
YEAH THIS SITUATION APPLIES IF
YOU MANIPULATED CONTACT SO
YOU'RE JUST PLACING A PART OF
THE SPEECH. THAT'S A PART OF
THE SPEECH AND IF YOU DON'T
CHANGE THE TONE OR IF YOU DON'T
TO CHANGE THE SPEED OR YOU
DON'T CHANGE THE WORDS THAT ARE
BEING SAID. THEN THEN I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT THIS BILL WOULD
APPLY TO THAT SITUATION. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY HAVE A BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE WANT TO CLOSER
ANY CLASSROOM VOTE YEAH. AND
QUIRK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
THE MOTION IS WORTH
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE SENATE.
YEAH BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE.
GALLAGHER NINE THIRTY CAL BY.
WELL I MEAN MAYES AYE MULLIN
MULLIN. WHEREVER. SIX BILLS OUT
SIX THANK YOU. GOING BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WITH THAT WE ARE IN
GERMANY